any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable in magic
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast production of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at UC san diego i am your
very fearful host Bryan Keating
co-director of the arthur c-- clark
center and today it's a great privilege
and joy to welcome a friend from a
completely different discipline in
cosmology and that's none other than dr.
martin a dr. Martin I just had a PhD
student graduate his name is Martin
so my 16th student got slipped in there
confused with you dr. Adam riess Adam
sorry for that slip-up how are you doing
today I'm good how are you I'm doing
good you know we first met I was trying
to think back when we when we met and I
realized it was a while ago and and that
was probably during this Templeton
Foundation sponsored young scientist
competition
ba ba ba to find the best scientist
under age 40 which you know I have to
say I did win and what I'm curious about
I think all my listeners are curious
about are you ever going to get over
that out of my ever gonna be okay I'll
tell you I've had in kind of an
inferiority complex since then
especially around you what I remember
I'd it was it was Charlie towns is 90th
birthday yeah and it was at Berkeley and
yeah and it was it was a an interesting
time lots of intellectual discussion and
I remember you were presenting results I
think that early bicep results yeah it
was designed a bicep we were about to
Commission it at the South Pole and that
was right a couple months before we
actually ended up shipping it out of
town and bring it down there and you
know I have to say he did a pretty good
job the organizers because the sub I
think the subtext of the of the
symposium was to identify Nobel caliber
discoveries and you know at least
between the between the two of us we
have one Nobel Prize so I think I did a
good job with that and I was thinking
about you and I was preparing for the
show and there's a quote and I have it
in my book and your major character in
the book as you know but in the book I
say a quote from
TS Eliot and we said it was a Nobel
Prize winner in literature II said the
Nobel is a ticket to one's funeral no
one has ever done anything after he got
it no I have to say I think you're a
counterexample to this laureate Elliot
hopefully rumors of my demise have been
greatly exaggerated but I rather think I
remember about you is every conference
where we've ever been at together I
always note that you're you listen with
one year but you're always tight but
you're always working you're always
thinking pondering and I wonder you know
first question I have you know because I
want to get into some of the weeds
technical weeds but I think I asked my
listeners for some questions for you and
a lot of them want to know what's it
like personally what kind of routines
what kind of habits and and so first of
all can you can you just tell a little
bit about where you grew up where you're
from and talk us through it a day in the
life of Adam Reese sure so I grew up in
New Jersey kind of central New Jersey
you know pretty normal I guess I would
say typical the period of played a lot
of soccer in school you know hung out
with friends was always interested in
science though without a doubt and
certainly the big I would say catalyst
for me really was a summer program that
they ran in New Jersey called the
Governor's School of Science and they
pick a hundred students throughout the
state to come for a month during the
summer between I think junior and
senior-year and that during that time
you would take sort of advanced courses
and get exposed to certain kinds of
material and at that time I took a
course in relativity my first sort of
exposure to really weigh out science and
you know I found special relativity to
be just mind-blowing
I mean I thought it was just I mean
anybody who ever takes you know a little
relativity knows or anybody's watch Star
Trek those these concepts of you know
aging changing as you travel through
space at great speeds and lengths
contracting and that whole thing seems
like science fiction yet that's the real
science so that got me pretty fired up
to pursue physics
and then I went to MIT got my PhD at
Harvard and worked my way from Berkeley
as a postdoc to the Space Telescope
Science Institute and Johns Hopkins and
a typical day for me I sort of wear two
hats I work on calibrating the Hubble
Space Telescope which I really enjoy and
is important for the kind of work I do
and then I teach at Johns Hopkins I
teach the sort of big intro to Astro
soar Astro 101 sort of course I am a
number of postdocs and graduate students
and mostly we're just engaged in
research trying to understand the nature
of the universe
and question that people wanted me to
ask is what would you do if you weren't
an astronomer and the parallel universe
wow that's yeah that's tough I really
like history quite a lot so I was a
minor in history I'd certainly thought
about something in that world I saw I
have a number of friends who made the
jump from doing data analysis about the
universe to data analysis of various
kinds of financial and market data and
know I mean there's so many interesting
things out there it's hard to say mm-hmm
and another kind of this is a Barbara
Walters section so you break down in
tears outside of work you mentioned
soccer or you still play that what kind
of hobbies do you have outside or yes I
like sports I love music and so I spend
a lot of time listening to music movies
books also I have a young family two
kids third grade and tenth grade and so
you know there's as we all know
especially during this time there's a
lot of homeschooling going on
so you know interesting quite a lot of
things and in terms of how you got to
where you're at and career-wise etc what
what would you attribute it more to is
it something that you had innately or
was something that was kind of brought
out in you maybe by an educator or a
mentor or first of all did you have
mentor
I know about perfect errors net cetera
was your PhD advisement and we are we
are friends as well and he's a woman
renowned for his mentorship but have you
had mentor mentor yet another I mean
I've been very fortunate I've had
wonderful mentors and I've also been
lucky to be at some great institutions
and to work with fantastic facilities
and even with great colleagues even
people weren't formerly my mentor but I
was on one very large team in the
beginning the Heisey supernova team and
there were some really great mentors
just to sort of you know you learned the
way science is done was so important but
you know I would say for me curiosity a
very strong curiosity has been a driving
force you know I don't consider myself
the smartest person in the field but I
feel like I make up for in being fairly
dogged in my pursuit of puzzles yeah
yeah as I said I mean literally I don't
know of anyone who has a harder you know
working reputation than you and in terms
of actually just witnessing you you know
they say a man's character a woman's
character is revealed when they think
nobody's looking
I remember once you know watching I was
driving down the street near a synagogue
that I was going to and I saw the rabbi
pull out and I was wondering you know is
he gonna cross the double yellow line
nobody's watching you know he had to go
the opposite and he didn't he waited for
the I was like you know that's not true
signs so I think it's certainly true
that you have that I wonder you know
when you get to the high and this will
be kind of the last question well
there's one more question from that life
that have tunes they ask you do you ever
get this you know in academia we have
this kind of hunger games that I call
the academic Hunger Games where you
start off you know you're at MIT or in
those competitive places in the world
and you have to beat out you know get
good grades there get letters
recommendation go to graduate school get
a good you know thesis project work
really hard write some papers get first
off or do this get a postdoc get a
faculty job give it and then eventually
the develop rise or get promoted do you
ever feel like that scheme is maybe
broken or detrimental mental health wise
and I don't have one follow-up to that
but the other night have you think I
think that is not a great scheme
as you described I feel lucky and that I
did not feel compelled by that scheme
early on I decided science was really
interesting to me and I would pursue it
as long as it was fun and engaging but
that I wouldn't pursue it you know for
you know checking certain boxes along
some path it was not part of my success
plan that I had to even you know become
a professor I sort of wanted to get a
PhD and spend some time in the field and
so I think that if people find
themselves trying to you know check
boxes you know complete a list to get to
a certain place they're probably in the
wrong field because science is a lot of
fun if you're driven by your own sort of
curiosity and passion I would say like
most things most occupations and so you
know if you feel that way you might work
really hard from the outside people will
think you're working hard but you know
from the inside you might feel like you
never work a day in your life because
you know if what you're doing is so
compelling interesting and you know as I
said we're blessed that science is one
of those kinds of fields that draws
people who are just sort of curious and
passionate you know we don't have to you
know undertake some of the things that
we do in science we do them because we
want to know the answers and other
people do too do you ever feel this this
this kind of contrasting set of emotions
that some academics told me about and
even I felt myself you know kind of
there's a contrast between fear of
missing out fear of not being sighted
not being credited attributed and then
there's kind of the imposter syndrome
which is almost the opposite you ever
you know kind of feelings about those
two conflicting yeah those are great
questions you know I think early on
first of the imposter syndrome right I
sort of realized for most of us in
science there's a very narrow niche that
we really become quite knowledgeable
about and so you know I was able to sort
of recognize you know it's really just
that niche that I know it's not you know
the broader picture and then you know
when you know the Nobel Prize happens
you know first of all as I said it was
never really my goal or Target and
second of all I quickly realized you
know it's not an IQ test it's not a it's
not a a ranking of great physicists it's
for people who for the most part were
lucky that they were in a right place at
the right time and contributed to a
discovery and that really could be you
know almost anybody in the field and so
I feel like I you know I'm not I'm Stein
and I would never pretend to be and I'm
sort of satisfied saying you know I have
expertise in a tiny niche and I was
lucky and that's you know that what's
that I don't have to impersonate anybody
that's that's the truth so yeah I it's
rumored that Einstein made a couple of
blunders that I want to get yes have we
did correct some of those that's right
so yeah very few people can say that
they actually superseded Einstein I want
to get into that but first I want to
take a step back when did the Astronomy
bug so to speak first bite you and and
where do you view sort of your place in
this history of astronomy starting with
the first optical observant
observational astronomer Galileo and
then you and and Brian Schmidt and Saul
Perlmutter one really the first Nobel
Prize for an optical observational
astronomy discovery if I'm not mistaken
right how do you view that is there a
way teenis to that that or is it just
wrong you know like you said you're kind
of doing it for fun you might be a you
know pro soccer player if this was like
I would not have been for sure but uh
yeah so you know in terms of astronomy
and my first interest in it you know I
was like a lot of kids you know standing
outside looking up at the stars and
really being unable to fathom what was
really out there but you know was a
casual conversation I had with my dad
when you know maybe I was seven or eight
with him pointing out that stars are so
far away that what we're seeing is
really the way they were millions of
years ago and some of those stars may
even be gone now and not just wrapping
my head around that this kind of image
of a star not being there but the light
traveling it just it just gets into
those juicy issues of
you know physics and these really
fascinating aspects of it and then in
terms of pursuing optical Astronomy you
know again that's to me where some of
the most interesting questions just
happen to be at the time that I was
going to graduate school these questions
like how old is the universe I mean who
would have think in graduate school you
could even begin to tackle a question
like that or you know what is the
ultimate fate of the universe and then a
number of things happen sort of right at
the right time the development of
certain tools for measuring the universe
like these exploding stars called type
1a supernovae so my thesis involved
improving the measurements and the
ability their ability to calibrate the
universe and then that quickly led to
these projects that our team and
promoters team did which was to push
those measurements further back in time
and look at how the trajectory of the
universe the expansion rate what we
thought would be slowing down and it's
that we found our great surprise it was
speeding up right and in that context
you know I want to take take our
listeners and viewers back in time so
behind me if you're watching on YouTube
you'll see an image of a galileo
galilei's prison where he was imprisoned
in 1634 and so after writing the
dialogue oh and there's a wonderful new
book we had on mario livio recently
discuss galileo and this book but you
know I noted when I stuck in a Mario
that you know Callie and you know it's
pretty beautiful prison I think America
Bernie Madoff would trade for a dollar
and what is it about astronomy you know
or kind of the cosmological that it was
a defense to our friends who study you
know convective flows and condensed
matter physics you know really excites
the mind and really does things that
piss off people like Einstein when he's
reputed to have said when he first saw
you know LeMay Tros conjecture that
there could have been a big bang he said
your physics is atrocious and what is it
about astronomy in particular maybe the
connection to cosmology specifically
that irritates and is so provocative in
your opinion yeah I think that uh
cosmology
has the kind of audacity to address
these really big questions like how did
this all start and where's it all going
and first of all you know there are a
lot of people who feel that well that's
not a question for science that's a
question for philosophy or for religion
and you know there there's a you know
there's a certain realm in which
cosmologists address these things we
don't say why there should be a universe
or you know what one should do in the
universe but you know the the sort of
the kinematics the the the motions the
distances these are things that we can
address and and questions of how long
has this been going on and so you know
people like Fred Hoyle getting you know
very upset at the idea of a big bang
moment you know having a strong
philosophical view about that and so
cosmology draws us to the possibility of
addressing those really big questions
which you know is where a lot of
controversy can be as well yeah so
moving into controversies the kind of
immediate aftermath of Einstein's theory
of general relativity in the early 1920s
was something which which I think would
mean ice to revive as a tradition
there's something called the great
debates and they took place not far from
you in Washington DC and this was famous
these Curtis Lyford debates and you've
actually written a wonderful treatment I
think in physics today magazine and and
you know you've done some some writing
and expository work for the public what
so in that context it was really
professionals debating you know the kind
of size and the structure and maybe the
kinematics or evolution of the universe
nowadays we you know proof if anybody
needed it that you are not just resting
on your laureate laurels is that you
know you're deeply involved in pointing
out that there may be a need for perhaps
a second series of great debates so I
wanted to move now to this to this
article that you and I were both quoted
in in the simmetry magazine I think it
was about a year ago called the nine
percent difference and this is really a
startling discovery which I think you
know you in all honesty you were played
it would play perhaps the first
foundational Bowl in bringing it at
least to attention of cosmologists and
then you went through and have been
doing some of them hosts yeoman workmen
like work towards understanding what's
happening so very brief I know you've
spoken about this nauseam but and I'll
have a link to folks and they are to the
article in show notes can you explain
what is this nine percent different
matter and so so you know over the last
20 years we have sort of arrived at what
we call the standard model of cosmology
you know this is sort of our greatest
hopes and dreams is to say we understand
the universe and when we say that we
really mean we have a model a story
there's physics there's components we
can explain from the beginning to the
end how the universe would expand and I
would say that's been very successful
and so ours today is called lambda-cdm
as you know stands for dark energy cold
dark matter and the other physics that
we know but the truth is we don't really
understand very well the nature of dark
matter and dark energy so it's very
important to keep testing this model and
as you know and maybe some of your
listeners know some of the most precise
measurements we get of the universe
ironically occurred just after the Big
Bang in the cosmic microwave background
radiation you get a very precise picture
of the universe and very precise
measurements of how fast it's expanding
and you know it's a little bit like if
you had a child you know they're born
maybe they're two years old you can
measure their height extremely well now
if we understand this model of the
universe then we ought to be able to
explain then how that process continues
how the universe expands over the next
thirteen billion years and we should be
able to predict how fast it should be
expanding today just like with that
child you could predict how tall they
will become eventually and then you go
out and say okay let me actually go
measure how fast the universe is
expanding today and what we're finding I
would say with the pretty high
consistency through multiple techniques
and methods is whenever we measure how
fast the universe is expanding today
with different methods we always get a
higher number and quite significantly
then this very precise measurement at
early times coupled with the prediction
based on our understanding of the
universe so it's like you predicted the
height of that kid and then he or she
grew to be you know two feet taller and
then then you expect it now that would
be really weird with a person because
we've seen many people grow we know what
the growth chart looks like but we only
have one universe we don't get to say
well this is what's normal for a
universe and of course on top of that
are these unknown parts 95% of the
universe in the form of dark matter and
dark energy and we don't really
understand the physics of them you know
cosmologists are very good at giving
names for ignorant and making it sound
like we sort of know what's going on we
say the simplest version the most
vanilla version of dark manner in dark
energy would have these properties and
what we're seeing at some level is the
universe isn't quite matching that
vanilla description so you know is this
going to tell us about a new wrinkle in
the universe you know I don't know I
mean it's a very hard problem as you
know to even understand you know what
exactly that could be and so many of us
continue to work on improving the
precision of the measurements and sort
of this you know the the way science
works between theorists coming up with
ideas of what might explain it and
experimentalists and observers like
myself trying to get finer and finer
measurements to sort of parse those
different possibilities and what do you
say that you know there are a lot of
tensions in cosmology and I think as I
said in that article you know the field
as a whole could use some good
psychoanalysis perhaps but there are
some who say that not only is attention
overwrought you know perhaps there is no
tension I'm speaking of in particular
group in Oxford led by subir Sarkar and
others that say you know things like is
there really a Hubble tension so right
and Sarkar actually goes even further
and says is there really dark energy at
all right right but what do you mean I
mean he's that what is he the lead of
theoretical physics at Oxford I mean
he's a very esteemed you know professor
in this field to get the researcher what
what do you make of these kinds of
attacks and
so you know the you know the fundamental
problem with dark energy or the
cosmological constant is the naive
explanation is 120 orders of magnitude
off from our sort of naive explanation
of what it should be or how big it
should be and so in a way that gives
infinite rope to people who are going to
express doubts particularly about the
data and say look you know I'm gonna not
use this data and I won't use this data
I'm going to throw away this data I'm
just going to cherry-pick this piece of
the data and I'm gonna do this kind of
funky analysis that one normally doesn't
do but I can do in this situation and as
I said they sort of have infinite rope
because you know it seems so
preposterous that there would be you
know this 120 order magnitude match and
yet that's what the data actually says I
mean I'm a big believer in not censoring
the data in that way and so when subir
looks at the data he discards this
cosmic microwave background data and
baryon acoustic oscillation data and
lensing data and knowledge of the mass
we have of the universe and ultimately
ends up with the closest he can get to
get away from dark energy is actually of
an empty universe where there's zero
matter or dark energy and that's still
in tension with the data and so you know
I think we learned the most by sort of
letting the data sort of guide us
through the universe because our dr our
ideas have not been very successful sort
of Nishio you know Einstein himself you
know was sort of fooled early on in his
career in trying to understand the
universe and how it would expand and and
dynamic yeah and do you think as I you
know as as I have you know kind of
spoken out with some other authors and
and intellectuals on the show there is
this notion that scientists are somehow
immune from the very biases that make
human being as human beings such as
confirmation bias being one of the ones
that's pretty prominent going back all
the way to Galileo and even his own
imprisonment was somehow
related to the fact that at all cost he
wanted to kind of go through the
Copernican hypothesis even when the day
of the examples he use were were wrong
or and he didn't use the best data that
he had already collected as Mario points
out in his most recent book but I think
nowadays you know we kind of have this
you know clinging to your priors or
reversion to your priors and
it's almost like the priors are becoming
you know as someone's like confirmation
bias is now entering in as a part of
Bayesian methodology because of his
priors that one must apply and I wonder
you know with people like Einstein the
thing about him although it's not really
clear if he actually said you know is
lambda was his biggest blunder the
cosmological term I think Mario goes
through and maybe debunked said in an
earlier book but but nevertheless he had
the Magnum Magnum D and the and the
intellectual honesty to say that yeah he
was wrong about this expansion what do
you make of the kind of the passion that
in particular the work that you no one
does I get these letters every day you
know professor Keating I've discovered
the Einstein was wrong you know if you
help me publish this I'll share the
Nobel Prize with you I I imagine you
don't need those you know reply to two
minute answer one of those letters and
it all worked out Einstein was given bad
information he was told at the time that
the universe was static said it wasn't
expanding or contracting and at the time
you know astronomers didn't understand
the difference between the Milky Way and
the universe and so you know Einstein
was not really a victim of his own
biases so much as a victim of bad data
and you know he was trying to make the
mess the best of bad data given this you
know incorrect information that the
universe was static you know he sought a
way to bring balance the the tendency of
a universe was matter in it to start to
collapse if it was static and some way
to oppose that and he made this
remarkable discovery that the gravity of
empty space itself can be repulsive can
hold them back you know in a way right
he discovered the greater
another feature of his theory of general
relativity which then as you know sort
of went into hiding or dormant for a
while as we knew the universe to be
expanding that Einstein wasn't given the
right date at the time and then we sort
of reinvented so you know I've never
really seen it as a blunder of eyes on
it but we sort of seen it as another
statement of his sort of brilliance to
be able to in 1916 you know discover the
possibility that empty space can have
repulsive gravity and for us in 1998 to
say you know I think he was right so
well to provide evidence yes and it
looked like he was right yeah I always
say his biggest blunder was saying it
was his biggest blunder yeah thanks to
you and your teammates so I'm showing on
the screen here for those watching
online that this model of so-called the
Big Crunch and you may know there's
another cosmic controversy as our
friends might say across the pond which
is you know whether or not inflation
took place and this isn't a set of
crackpots you know I always say that
people that email me Einstein was wrong
I always write back well let me know
what you think about Boltzmann you know
it's always they always choose Einstein
like everybody else I don't know if you
ever played Dungeons & Dragons yeah you
killed somebody and then you get their
hit points are you somebody's army and
risk if you get all their armies you
know you becomes right do you because
you get Einsteins mantle if you're not
gotten spun off its mantle and sometimes
I see that you know there's more than
one person who's you know come out and
said you know there's problems with the
data there's problems with with the
supernova data there are these issues I
think you know again with the higher you
fly as as my Italian friend told me in
Italian but I can't remember it you know
the easier you are to shoot down because
when people should understand and I just
want to point this out that um you know
cosmology is hard there's no question
the data is difficult to acquire and
analyze what leads to consensus in our
field generally is when as you know many
different kinds of data that probe the
universe in very different ways come to
the same conclusion
likewise for theory when you know many
different theorists thinking about
things in very different ways come to
similar conclusions and you're
friends who write you these messages
about you know I have this theory of the
universe and you know and you wonder you
know is this right is this person a
crackpot
you know we wonder this all the time I
tend to notice many of those people each
of them has a completely different idea
they don't succeed in convincing anybody
else of their sort of you know
outlandish idea so you know this is part
of the science process is we are able to
reproduce the truth or reality whereas
you know a mistake or an error here or
there is generally not reproduced in
data set after data set
likewise with theory you know different
mathematical ideas are not something
that you can develop and come to from a
different direction keep arriving at the
same place and so it's this it's this
reproducibility that really defines what
is special I think about science and
generally leads us to think we're on the
right track hmm
and so getting back to this you know
discussion of another controversy the
the existence or lack thereof of an
inflationary epoch this has come
alongside it I think both the discovery
of dark energy and the discovery of
cosmic acceleration and the discovery of
inflation or things that are consistent
with inflation bring up very startling
conclusions about in one sense the very
early universe which has a concomitant
you know kind of co-equal prediction
that there we live in a multiverse
if the inflationary model is correct
because it's almost impossible to
develop models of inflation that don't
feature multiverse like extensions to
them you can but it's very difficult
according to the two or three foremost
proponents of it and so that's led
people as it has with the discovery of
the accelerating universe to speculate
about the implications of the theory I
want to get into that a little bit later
but first thing on the technical side do
you feel that some of the these
implications of just acceleration itself
do you feel like they will be were found
to be related to say the inflationary
epoch I mean they're both exponential
potentially again and so expansions over
operating over different time scale yeah
I'll even draw
in there would you know the Hubbell
tension right now is the appearance that
they're still some sort of anomalous
additional expansion and you know we
feel like there could be maybe as many
as three episodes you know inflation
acceleration and whatever is causing the
hobble tension which could have been you
know anomalous expansion is sort of at
an in-between time shortly after
recombination or before recombination
these are things that are not easily
addressed in our understanding gravity
without invoking some kind of energy of
empty space and so you know it just may
be that you know this is really an area
of physics that we're just beginning to
sort of scratch the surface of that you
know we see the universe go through
occasional periods of this anomalous
expansion we're attributing it to excess
energy in space and you know maybe at
some point we will understand how they
have some relationship between each
other you know some ability to even
predict or connect them I mean I don't
I'm not aware of it right now but it's
very compelling when you see something
happen you know for there certainly is a
second if not the third time just start
saying you know haven't I seen this
movie before you know sometimes you know
we you know our colleagues like to talk
about anytime you invoke something
strange going on well you're invoking
the Tooth Fairy and you know you're
allowed to do that maybe once and you
know my question becomes you know how
many invocations of the Tooth Fairy is
it exactly to have inflation and
acceleration and maybe even Hubble and
to mention is that one is that three I
don't it's hard to kill yeah and
certainly you know our colleagues are
nothing if not creative and the
theoretical sense and coming up with
ideas and I do want to talk to you about
one idea that's my pet favorite for
resolution potentially of the hobble
tension and that's the existence of
primordial magnetic fields and her talk
free gave recently on another competing
YouTube channel so I'm not gonna mention
is deny I just I can't pronounce his
name but but you Gia cosmology lecture
you get yes and you were sort of a
little bit dismissive of the idea that
you know you made a kind of an offhand
quip that you know when we were in
graduate school we
if you can't explain sir you may
remember from my dog but we did that
only because it was so hard they sort of
like cover for it for anything it was
like uh and in the area we all know we
don't understand there's magnetic fields
right so that I mean you know there's a
there's a certain sensibility to sort of
say a phenomenon we don't understand the
excess Hubble expansion and a thing we
don't understand you know maybe they
explain each other I mean I don't know
right well I'm one of the leading ideas
now maybe that you know if you have
primordial magnetic fields then these
can change the way the early universe
operates and quantity we like to
calculate called the sound horizon that
lies underneath the ability to predict
the Hubble constant expansion of the
universe yeah so that's the ISO for my
little quip and retort to your equip you
know as arthur c clarke said for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert set for every clip there's an
equal and opposite clip so I kind of
view primordial magnetic fields as the
parents instead of the tooth fairy
because we know that magnetic fields
exist on all structures that are
gravitationally bound we have yet to
discover a truly you know all pervasive
cosmological field that's not
gravitationally bound but you might I
give a talk at Hopkins last last May I
guess it was and I mentioned that
there's a lower limit on a primordial
magnetic field strength from the non
observation of these TeV Blazers that do
not have these GeV halos around it and
so now the lower limit is pretty
breathtakingly small you talk about
fine-tuning it's about a micro nano
Gauss as I'd like to call it and the
limits that we're making from CMB
experiments such as polar bear Simon's
array act spt bicep etc are on the level
of about a nano Gauss maybe a little bit
lower than that but a lot of the tests
that we're looking for that proba
magnetic field strength are relying on
the Sam B's what are called these power
spectrum so you may be correlation
functions you Fourier transform them and
you get the power spectrum that sort of
sensitive to the magnetic field to the
fourth power I believe so it's very hard
to make progress against things that
scale as the fourth power it's for the
first measurement you do you pick all
the low-hanging fruit but there's
another complimentary approach that
we're starting to invoke with our
colleagues and Simon's Observatory and
other projects around the world which is
look for Faraday rotation which is
linear in the magnetic field strength so
that will produce a signal that would
cause polarization rotation and for
those reasons I think I think you need a
background source for that well use the
c mb z mode so we know that sandy has a
modes and then we know the plasma had
free electrons and so the question is do
those fields survive too and it's
exactly the epoch that you care about
you always have this really prescient
you know observation that you know how
do you define the early universe well
it's when neutrinos are important
exactly and I think you could say you
know if you could find these magnetic
fields which are ubiquitous I mean we
have them in our bodies and we have in
our solar system and beyond so you know
if you could find that I think that
would require the least modification to
the laws of physics
you know Nima akane Hamed oh he says
like people that look for violations of
the standard model people like me you
know looking for these departures from
them from the so-called standard model
really you know maybe going down a
fool's errand because it's very hard to
break the standard - yeah but then when
we talk about things like the Hubble
tension you know we're looking for a
wrinkle not you know a paradigm change
and so like you said something like a
magnetic field in the early universe you
know I think probably magnetic fields is
sort of in the same position that the
cosmological constant was 20-30 years
ago in fact I would say well I don't I
don't know really how to calculate or
figure out what it should be
our priori I guess it's zero you know
zero wasn't a good guess and it was not
really we didn't have a profound reason
why that ought to be but you know
physicists like simplicity so something
is rearing its ugly head at the moment
right then we say well it's zero so
maybe magnetic fields primordial I've
been you know zero for so long and then
at some point we'll go you know actually
there's this meme that I know that part
of your productivity stems from the fact
that you don't use social media yes
unlike me so there's a meme on Twitter
that's my secret secret weapon there's a
meme on social media that when everybody
says something about like new cure for
kovat or whatever cancer and that you
should always add just say in
or you know just say - always it's
always like 8,000 kind of copy
equivalent in a mouse or kill yeah
so I always say you know the equivalent
in cosmology should be just say dust and
yes you know one of the things I did the
research in my for my book I came upon
some papers that you wrote with Bob
Kirchner and others back in the 90s and
mid 90s again very very trenchant Lee
observing that there could be prosaic
explanations for what we were seeing and
I wonder you know and even things that
come about now like this tabby star or
you see things you know these these more
and more are things like you see all
this evidence for literally the litter
of the cosmos basically dust I
interviewed and Riaan is Carl Sagan's
Widow on Friday last Friday as well and
you know she we were just talking about
that the pale blue dot is really the
speck of dust floating on a sunbeam and
it's really just highlights the
pervasion the pervasive kind of ability
for dust to stymie observations on one
hand and another hand to kind of point
directions to new fields of research so
I wonder do you you've done some
research in a really wonderful paper
I'll put a link to as well which is just
like this this you're just doing the
work I mean you're saying like is
Cepheid crowding I don't want to get
into it now but you're actually looking
at the you know at the systematic errors
so so the difference between a physical
error which can be reduced with more
data and a systematic or this intrinsic
to your system or the cosmos itself is
very profound and it's much harder I
think to get rid of these systematic
errors so are there still systematic
errors that you would point to I mean I
always wonder like how well do we know
the astronomical unit you know like
that's off by 1% there half a percent
pretty good with that we've done radar
ranging off the Sun you know it's the
way you find systematic errors is you
give talks and you listen to your
colleagues and your colleagues generally
ask good questions and instead of just
dismissing the MA there can't be that
right you kind of have to talk them okay
and make a little note of that you know
and you sit around you try to think of
ways to answer your colleagues mom and
you know they might seem at the time
especially you know when you're first
starting in research oh there's such
unfair questions you know how
when you're about to publish a paper
that is right by the way right that's
right but you know you really will do
well to listen to those critics and then
try and come up with an experiment or a
measurement or a test and if it succeeds
go back to them and say you know is this
convincing or not and then you know
continue the process basically until you
know we'd like to say and it's true you
know Carl Sagan said extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
so you know I always thought that I had
his daughter on and as well as Michael
Shermer on recently I said you know I
don't like all of a sudden like my
students comes to me with some data and
I say that's data but I need
extraordinary like it's either good or
it's bad it's just how much power type
in the kind of beza and prior to that
it's right and in a way how large a
claim are you making how you know how
much supports this and so you know I've
been fortunate to be around a few things
that required extraordinary evidence and
it's you know it's hard and it takes you
know it's more than any one investigator
or team or group can do it takes really
the community you know firing at things
in different ways and you know we've all
seen you know very well you wrote a book
about a result that you know you know
soft the extraordinary evidence and you
know learned about you know the
difficulties of dust and you know the
community is pretty good at you know
digging into these things asking these
questions and you know it's rare I don't
know in my experience that's something
that's just flat-out wrong survives that
onslaught very law mmm-hmm yeah exactly
so I want to turn now we've discussed
that I think you go through in your talk
on this cosmology channel I'll put a
link to it you know what you're kind of
pet theory is I mean to the extent that
you're willing to even say there's a
there's a pet theory but I've always
wondered like what would you how much
would you pay for a supernova to go off
at like redshift of five I mean just
settle everything in your fear well that
would be nice I don't want might even be
better if one went off in the Milky Way
way we can measure parallax to it right
and so we would we'd skip some of these
steps we use intermediary
to calibrate things but you know one
went off I mean not too close I don't
want to singe anybody exactly I think
you'd like to see when I take out some
colleagues so if I could beam in at
certain places but anyway now I'm you
know if we don't had some in the Milky
Way we'd measure parallax and you can
calibrate these great standard candles
you know even better probably than we
have mm-hmm exactly so we talked about
different different tensions and so
forth any other tensions that are
particularly interesting to you yeah you
know there are I mean you know to my
view the Hubble constant tension is
probably the largest in significance but
there are other kind of you know what we
call curiosities you know there's
something I've always noticed in the
cosmic microwave back at the the power
spectrum as a function of frequency or L
you tend to get somewhat different
parameters over different ranges of L so
when two different experiments basically
measure the power spectrum over the same
range of L they tend to get consistent
results which tells me that the
experiments actually look pretty good it
makes me wonder if the underlying model
is the thing that actually changes with
L because you know and you probably seen
this as well you look at the
cosmological parameters around L of a
thousand and maybe you get a Hubble
constant closer to 70 and you do it more
like at LM 2000 and it kind of drifts
down to 64 then you go out to even
higher L 2000-3000 drifts back up into
the low 70s and you know as I said when
other experiments re measure the same
patch of sky on the same frequency they
get consistent results so I'm not as
concerned about the experiments as I am
wondering and all these these sorts of
hints intentions are more at the 2 & 1/2
Sigma level they're not something that
all on their own you would draw a lot of
attention to but if you're trying to
solve a larger puzzle and you found a
solution or a story that we've done a
few of these things now some of the
people who work on you know ways of
altering the composition of the early
universe have made claims not only does
it solve the hubble tension but
it explains some of these variations
with L in the parameters or not only
does it explain the Hubble constant but
it helps with so they called the Sigma 8
tension which has to do with the sort of
chunkiness matter in the universe some
things make it works in which case you
know you go well that doesn't sound very
promising but so you know you do well to
pay attention to sort of all these clues
you know a lot of people say well it's
not you know 5 Sigma I don't want to
hear about it well yeah but if you're
trying to actually figure out the next
step you you know you pieced together a
bunch of three and four Sigma's and and
you know if you can find a story that
ties them all together
and you know can have the equivalent
significance yeah absolutely I think
about that in the context of you know
these topology measurements I did a
podcast at Janna Levin who wrote a book
called you know how the universe got its
spots about the topology and structure
of the universe those are still
outstanding questions axis of evil'
different axis of evil the dark spot the
cold spot yeah yeah I mean there's a you
know there's certainly a few funnies
that are hanging around and you know I
think smart people you know go to talks
and you know write write in their
notebook and draw a circle around the
funnies and they have their own
collection these are the ones I believe
look legitimate and you know they spend
time thinking how can I tell a story
that leads through a number of yeah
that's wonderful advice and that segues
nicely into segment I'm going to call
the big picture segment when we take a
step back I mentioned that we met first
time 2005 at this Templeton John
Templeton Foundation search for young
scholars and you know of course the
Templeton Foundation was is heavily
associated with searches for for
spirituality and and the concilium
between science and religion not that
it's to the exclusion of atheists who
won the Templeton Prize but one question
that I've had you know for for you the
character of your discovery is a little
bit different than say the blue LED or
even a transistor or something like that
or explaining a phenomenon that was
known to exist sort of retro addicting
it had been done in different cases
throughout history it was really a
serendipitous discovery I mean you
weren't looking for I claim in the book
as you might remember that you know
those are the pure
discoveries but I'm curious now in
relationship Templeton is you know does
your work have any influence on you
maybe this the way that you think about
your place in the history of science or
or does it affect you personally
religiously philosophically in any way
oh that's a good question that's a
really good question um you know I would
say not very much I mean I certainly
feel lucky or fortunate to be living in
interesting times as Confucius says and
you know I think there's no question
that you know we will look back on the
last 20 years in cosmology as a very
special time you know we like to call it
the era of precision cosmology but you
and I know right we went to graduate
school and at the time people were
saying yeah nobody knows whether you
know there's enough matter to close the
universe or not what the gauge of the
universe you know what the ultimate fate
of the universe is whether it's going to
wreak elapsed or not you know nobody
knows right the age of the universe and
the expansion rate you effective too and
I don't know about you but I just sort
of thought like if you show up in a
class and they tell you nobody knows
these things you know probably nobody
will ever know those things I mean
that's just like they're the swords and
the stones that are you know cast in
there you know a thousand years ago and
you're just gonna have to live with it
and you know you and I got to see a lot
of those poeple over the last 20 years
we don't know the answers to everything
but I would say we went from you know
almost like the pre Magellan view of the
world to you know post okay this is the
this is the basic parts on the map and
you know I just feel lucky that you know
we've been around during that time I
would be pretty much just as happy just
to have gotten to witness it and just
see it and learn about it and get to go
back to the last class and go actually
we know this stuff now we know that so
you know we're we all I think as as
humans are fortunate to be around during
the times when we've learned so many
profound things that you know address
people's basic curiosity about the
universe absolutely
so these are questions from laypersons
first one is do you feel differently in
your approach to science now that you
have won the Nobel Prize or do you still
feel the same as before
I don't think I have changed my approach
to it very much you know it may be to a
small degree it inspires me or reminds
me wow you never know what's lurking
around any corner you know do a basic
measurement do a basic test you know you
might find something but no I mean I
think you know science is science I mean
whether you're whether you're doing you
know your physics freshman lab
experiment or you know something with
the Hubble Space Telescope I mean
there's a process you state a hypothesis
you collect evidence for or against as
you find out when you analyze it I mean
that's that procedure it's a beautiful
procedure it's you know science really
has I think just about the best way of
getting to truth and things I mean we
can't answer everything but you know our
procedure if we follow it is really
really powerful that's right you know
absolutely I agree 100%
last question about the Nobel Prize
since I cannot resist I've got you here
I can ask anything I want you don't have
to answer anything is there anything
about the Nobel Prize that you would
change or is it pretty much okay yeah I
guess the thing I would change is the
size of the group that can be recognized
I mean you know I think it's you know
there's this is a holdover from a time
when science was literally done by a few
people that you know it probably was not
very limiting in the year 1900 to say
all right what are we gonna pick and we
don't want it to include more than three
people but today is you and I both know
science is done generally in large
groups or teams working together and you
know that kind of division of labor
allows us to do bigger and better more
exciting things we build off of each
other's work we don't just start out and
like an Einstein say I was just you know
having a beautiful thought and I
realized something amazing you know we
really were like I went to so-and-so's
talk and I heard this thing and I
thought I'll do one thing a little more
so you know I wish that the Nobel Prize
could go to recognize teams you know
sort of without limit in size fantastic
yeah the Peace Prize does that already I
say and you know no okay final questions
and then
can I'll take questions from the
audience meaning new first question I
have there's a concept that Alfred Nobel
of course was aware of when he endowed
his prize of a will a material will
where he left his his monetary and other
possessions physical possessions to
other people but there's also a concept
called an ethical will which is also
composed comprised within of Alfred
Nobel's will which is which is a notion
that you have a certain set of values
for higher higher thoughts or wisdom
that you want to communicate for Alfred
of course it's the famous catechism of
the of the nobel prize themselves which
is for the betterment of mankind and
these discoveries should should educate
towards not just in the peace prize but
but even in the physics price was to
better mankind so I want to ask you in a
120 years of life
you leave your ethical will not your
material will but what do you leave in
your ethical note yeah you know I think
the best sort of guiding advice or light
that I think comes directly from science
from physics from sort of everything
I've gone to experience is to be curious
that curiosity it's sort of being
Pythias unfortunately of what I think
many people in the world suffer from
today which is a kind of extreme
ideology where you know that's sort of
the opposite of curiosity you go and you
say you know I know everything already
and I'm just going to beat other people
over the head until they know it too and
it never works out that way scientists
going with a curiosity and then you
actually open your eyes and actually
learn about the way the world actually
works and often you're surprised I mean
in our know about work you were
extremely surprised about you know what
the universe was actually doing and so I
feel like as long as people in the
future can hold on to that curiosity to
go out sort of everyday question their
assumptions and go and look to see you
know what is real what is right what is
reality what is rational you know don't
be well-served hmm very nice so then
last of these questions actually there's
a second question so that's kind of what
you would leave in time now when I asked
you hearkening
- sir arthur c clarke s-- famous movie
2001 Space Odyssey so there of course
these these structures who are not quite
sure what they are they're these
monoliths that that actually exists and
are meant to be encountered by by human
beings perhaps and in fact some of them
drive the plotline forward I've asked
many people this question about if you
had to make a billion year time capsule
like such an object what kind of things
would you put on it or in it it could be
material it could be it could be an
equation I'm gonna put up an image that
that some friend of Mines have suggested
that they were put up it's based on the
famous wall this is at Sunnybrook
University it's kind of it's actually
made by Eric Weinstein's team yes and
yeah you can actually go to his portal
website and click on it and it takes you
through now some people have said that
some of these equations would be what
they carve into the wall and to the
round list over data Marie's carbon to
his you know there's this very
compelling idea I've seen before about
storing all the seeds of all the you
know every kind of plant vegetation
that's ever lived and you know consider
the complexity of the process that
evolution went through to realize each
of those you know I might put you know
an example of a seat if kind of Noah's
Ark of a plant world means of my
monolith the equations of course are
very appealing but if somebody took that
answer already asked that was seeds
actually that connects nicely to injury
ins but she talks about the scientists
who first came up with this idea in fact
during the siege of leningrad i believe
when they could have they starved to
death many people starve to death they
were still collecting seeds for this
project and they you know they could
have eaten them they could have done
whatever and that yet they didn't so
you're among a very very esteemed
intellect on history and that in that
choice last question are also harkens to
sir arthur c clarke and that's actually
the name of the podcast the name of the
podcast is into the impossible which is
an MC Clarke's third law his first laws
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from this the second
one I already read yeah and
third one is the only way to find out
what's possible is to venture beyond
them a bit into the impossible so my
question to Adam is going now we went
forward in time let's go back in time
what would you tell sort of a 20 year
old 30 year old Anna Maurice what wisdom
would you say that seemed impossible to
you at the time yeah but then you went
ahead and did it yeah you know to be
very honest you know I I knew I liked
science I found this subject very
fascinating but I didn't really think
there'd be a place or a career so you
know an actual way to do science to be
there very long I I just thought these
are great courses to take I love going
to you know my physics courses and I
love learning about these things but you
know you can't mean at some point I got
a you know grow up and get a job and and
I guess I could say to myself you know
keep following your passion I know it's
cliche but you know in my case it was
literally true yeah you know don't give
up until you know the doors been slammed
a hundred times and so you know I guess
it would be that that's great okay Adam
I think that brings us to the end of our
discussion there any other things that I
could have asked you should have asked
you didn't ask you that you'd like to
bring up let's see so what what happened
so you won so when we were at that a
contest you won first prize and I think
you got some prize money or something
what you do with what you do with the
prize much oh I spent it on my yacht
they the SS keno well actually to be
honest I did so I'm a practicing Jew I'm
not in for that aux jeux but we have a
tradition of mitzvah if you will to give
away 10% of our of our winnings and I
did do that I think it was like 20 grand
actually and this is in twenty two
thousand five dollars not the funny
money we use today I think I gave some
of it away and I think I did I I think I
did buy a pretty nice bike I actually
still have the bike that I bought it was
pretty fancy and I can't remember this
before kids so you know I guess the
thing I probably with all be gone now
you know on some iPads or whatever what
you do with your share of the Nobel from
and Oh
that's a great question I guess you know
money is kind of fun jabal you sort of
work you know what I do is this piece of
money you know believe it or not I mean
it's a lot of money but you know it's
still at the level you go well you know
both my kids go to college and you know
want to retire someday or whatnot you
know better kind of you know keep that
in the bank so you know I didn't do too
many dramatic things okay great
any other things you want to discuss
before we sign off hopefully we'll get
another chance to do this again yeah now
stay safe yeah thanks Adam
thank you so so so much sincerely you
are again a role model even for people
that are basically your age like me that
the work that you do is great meaning
and the fact that you do it with such
consistency regularity you have great
habits and these tactics and so forth
that we talked about you're really
you're really one of the one of the
dementias mensches that I know and I
want to just thank you for sharing so
much your time with us today
thank you any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable imagine
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please